dans sa politique de déploiement du
numérique le département des yvelines
danse et en 2016 yvelines numériques un
regroupement du département et des
intercommunalités on a un syndicat mixte
ouvert chargé du développement des
plateformes numériques de service public
on travaille dans deux domaines
essentiellement le numérique pour
l'éducation et nous déployons donc des
outils au bénéfice des élèves dès que
des parents d'élèves et de l'ensemble de
la communauté éducative notamment les
enseignants et nous travaillons
également dans le domaine de la sûreté
électronique où nous développons une
plateforme innovante qui permet de faire
remonter en temps réel un nombre d'image
d'un très grand nombre de sites un
service de vidéo protection déployée
dans tous les collèges du département
des robots dans les hôpitaux ou les
domiciles pour maintenir le contact
entre l'école et les enfants de nombreux
projets en cours de développement
c'était important de bénéficier de
locaux qui permettent justement tout ce
développement et qui permet de se
concentrer de travailler en groupe de
recevoir des partenaires du conseil
départemental de versailles yvelines
numériques a donc déménagé à guyancourt
dans ses nouveaux locaux plus modernes
et fonctionnels pour remplir ses
missions haut débit fin 2020 l'ensemble
du haut débit sera déployé dans la zone
blanche du département des yvelines de
deux façons soit par l'installation de
la fibre numérique choix parce qu'on
appelle la montée en débit c'est à dire
qu on équipe les réseaux cette journée
d'inauguration est également marquée par
le lancement du nouveau site internet du
syndicat mixte ouvert